the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so actually I have a I know where
people are working on projects and
you're not responsible for any material
new material in the lectures thank you
for coming but I do have something in an
important topic which is a revised
version about the construction of neural
nets the basic structure that we're
we're working with so that's on the open
web at section 7.1 that's so
construction of neural nets really it's
a construction of the learning function
f so that's the function that you
optimize by gradient descent or
stochastic gradient descent and you
apply to the training data to minimize
the loss you so just thinking about it
in a more organized way because I wrote
that section before I knew anything more
than how to spell neural nets but now
I'm thought about it more so the the key
point may be compared to what I had in
the past is that I now think of this as
a function of two sets of variables X
and V
so X are the weights and V are the
feature vectors the sample feature
vectors from the so those come from the
training data either one at a time if
we're doing stochastic gradient descent
with many batch size one or B at a time
if we're doing mini batch of size B or
the whole thing a whole epoch at once if
we're doing full-scale gradient descent
so so those are the feature vectors and
these are the numbers in in those in the
Mait in the linear steps where the
weights so they're the matrices a k that
you multiply by multiply V by and also
the bias vectors BK that you add on to
shift the origin okay and these are the
and these are it's these that you
optimize those are to optimize and
what's the structure of the whole the
whole of the learning function and how
do you use it what what does the neural
net look like so you you take f of a
first set of weight so f of the first
set of weights would be a1 and b1 so
that's the X part and the and the actual
sample vector the sample vectors
v zero in the iteration and this
produces and then you do the nonlinear
step to each component and that produces
V one
so there is a typical I could write out
what this is here a 1 V 0 plus V 1 so
that's the two steps are the linear step
you the input is V 0 you take the linear
step using the using the first weights a
1 and B 1 then you take the nonlinear
step and that gives you V 1 so that's
really better than my line above so I'll
erase that line above yep
so that produces V 1 from V 0 and the
first weight and then the next level
inputs v1 so I'll just call this VK or V
K minus 1 and I'll call this one VK okay
so so k equal to 1 up to however many
layers URL layers so the input was v-0
so this V is really v-0 you could say
and you this is the neural net and this
is the out input and output from each
layer and then V L is the final output
from the final layer so so let's just do
a picture here here here is v-0 a sample
vector or if we're doing image
processing it's all the pixels in in the
image in the in the in the data and the
training from one sample this is
one training sample and then you
multiply by a 1 and you add B 1 and you
take Riu of that vector and that gives
you V 2 V 1 sorry that gives you V 1 and
then you iterate to finally V L the last
layer you don't do real uu at the last
layer so it's just al V L minus 1 plus
VL and you may not do a bias vector also
at that layer but you might and that's
this is the finally the output so is
that picture and so that picture is
clearer for me than it was previously to
distinguish between the weights so in
the in the gradient descent algorithm
it's these X's that you're choosing the
V's are not these are given by the
training data that's not part of the
optimization part that's not part of its
X in chapter 6 where you're finding the
optimal weights so this X really stands
for X stands for the all the weights
that you compute up to a L be L so it's
that's that's a collection of all the
weights and the important part for
applications for practice is to realize
that there are often more weights and
more components in the weights then
there are components in the feature
vectors in the samples in the vs
so often the size of X is greater than
the size of V which is an interesting
and sort of unexpected situation so
often I'll just write that often the X's
are the weights X's are under determined
because the number of X's exceeds and
often far exceeds the number of visa
number of the cardinality the number of
weights in this is in the A's and B's
and the these are in the samples in the
training set the number well the number
of features of all the samples in the
training set so I'll get that new
section 7.1 up hopefully this week on
the on the open that's the open set and
I'll email to you on stellar is there
more I should say about this you see
here the I can draw the picture but of
course a hand-drawn picture is far
inferior to to a machine drawn picture
but online picture but let me just do it
so there's V the training sample has
some components and then they're
multiplied now here's going to be v1 the
first in layer and that can have a
different number of of of components in
in the first layer different number of
neurons and then each one comes from
from the
eze by so I won't keep going here but
but you you see the picture so there's a
mate that describes a matrix a one that
tells you what the weights are on those
and then there's a b1 that's added the
BIOS vector is added to all those to get
the v1
there's so v1 is a 1 V 0 plus B 1 and
then onwards so this this is the spot
we're drawing it by hand is clearly
inferior to any other possible way to do
it okay so now I haven't yet put into
the picture the loss function so that's
the function that you want to minimize
so what is the loss function so we're
choosing x2 that's all the A's and B's
to minimize the loss function el okay so
it's this part that Professor SRA's
lecture was about so he he said el is
often a finite sum over all the of F so
what would that be f of X V I so this is
the output from the with weights with
weights in X from sample number I and if
we're doing batch processing that is
we're doing the whole batch at once then
we compute that for all I and that's the
computation that's ridiculously
expensive and you go instead to
stochastic gradient and you just choose
one of those or B of those
small number be like 30 to 120 8 of
these F's but but full-scale gradient
descent chooses the weights X to
minimize the loss now so the law I
haven't got the loss here yet there is
this function the loss would be minus
the true result from sample I I don't
write I haven't got a good notation for
that I'm open to suggestions
so how do I want to write the air
suppose suppose I'm so that would be if
it was least squares I would maybe be
squaring that so that would be a sum of
squares of errors squared over all the
samples or if I'm doing stochastic
gradient descent I would minimize I
guess I'm minimizing this but the
question is do I use the whole function
L in at each iteration or do I just pick
one or only B of the samples to look at
at iteration number K so so this is the
this is the L of X then I've added up
over all the V's so just to keep their
notation straight I have this function
of X and V s I find its output
what would V what this is what to the
neural net produces it's supposed to be
close to the true we don't want it to be
exactly we we don't expect this to be
exactly zero but it it could be because
we have lots of weights to achieve that
so that's what anyway that would be the
loss we minimize and B squared for
square loss I guess I haven't really
spoken about the about loss functions
let me just put those here
and actually I these are popular loss
functions one would be the one we know
best square loss and number two I've
never seen it used quite this directly
would be the L one loss may be the sum
of L one norms this is some of these
error squared in the l2 norm you know
one loss could be there's some over I of
the l1 losses but that's not a well this
this comes into specific other problems
like lasso and are there other important
problems you're minimizing an l1 norm
but not in deep learning now and three
would be hinge loss probably some of you
know better than I the formula and the
background behind hinge loss is it for
this is four minus one one
classification problems rather than four
that would be appropriate for regression
so this would be for regression and then
finally the most important for neural
nets is cross-entropy loss
this is for neural nets so this is
really our the most used loss function
in the and the set up that we are mostly
thinking of and and I'll try to say more
about that before the course ends so is
that I don't know for me I hadn't got
this straight
until rewriting that section and it's
now bet in better form but comments are
welcome okay and so that just completes
what I wanted to say and you'll see the
new section any comments on that before
I go to a different topic entirely okay
oh and then questions let me before I go
to this topic which I'll tell you what
it is it's it's it's a short section in
the book called distance about distance
matrices and the question is if we're we
have we have a bunch of points in space
and what we know is we know the
distances between the points and it's
convenient to talk about distances
squared here
okay and how would we know these
distances maybe by radar or or any
measurement they might be sensors which
we've placed around and we can measure
the distances between them and the
question is what's their position so
that's the yeah that's the question so
let me talk a little bit about this
question and then pause find positions
and well in space but I don't know we
don't know ahead of time maybe whether
the space is ordinary 3d space or
whether these are sensors in a plane or
whether we have to go to higher
dimensions I'll just put D and and we
also I'll just say then we're also
finding D and what are these positions
these are positions X X I so the
distance between X I minus XJ squared is
is the given D IJ so we're given
distances between them and we want to
find their positions find their so we
know distances and we want to find
positions that's the question and it's
just a neat math question that is solved
and you'll see a complete solution and
and it has lots of applications and it's
yeah it's just a nice it's a nice
question so it occupies a section of the
book but that section is only two pages
long because it's just a straightforward
solution to that question given the
distances find the positions given the
distances find the XS
okay so I'm gonna speak about that let
me I had a suggestion a good suggestion
by email
well questions about the projects coming
in projects are beginning to come in and
at least at the beginning I'm I make
well out in all cases beginning and end
I'll read them carefully and as long as
I can I'll stand back suggestions for
our final rewrite and as I said so I'd
like to get a print out is great you
could leave it in the envelope outside
my office
but of course online is it's what
everybody's doing so those are just
beginning to come in and they're not if
we can get them in by a week from today
I'm really really happy yep and just
feel free to email me I would email me
about projects rather than not Jonathan
and not not anonymous stellar I think
you probably better just ask me that
question that's that's fine and I'll try
to answer you in a useful way
yeah so that's and I'm always open to
questions so you could email me like how
long should this project be my tutor in
Oxford said something like when he you
know you were writing essays that's the
Oxford system is to write an essay and
he said just start where it starts and
end when it finishes so that's the
that's the idea
certainly not normally long and then a
question was raised and I can ask you if
you are interested in that
the question was what courses after this
one are natural are sort of natural to
take to go forward and I don't know how
many of you
who are thinking to take have time to
take another MIT other MIT courses in
this area of deep learning machine
learning optimization all the topics
we've had here anybody expecting to take
more courses just stick up a hand yeah
and you already know like what MIT
offers or so that was the question that
came to me what does MIT offer in this
direction and I haven't looked up to see
the number of professors roz course sra
but after in course six it's six point
high number and and after his good
lecture I think that's gotta be
worthwhile so I looked on course six I
didn't find a really very an institute
wide list maybe course six feels that
they are the Institute but there's other
courses around and but I found in in the
operations were a search site oh are see
the operations Research Center let me
just put there this is just in case you
would like to think about any of these
things so there as I write that so I
heard the lecture by Tim berners-lee
that others here that this a week or so
ago he created the web so it's a pretty
amazing
it wasn't Al Gore after all and you know
do you know his name what he's now Sir
Tim berners-lee so that double name
makes you suspect it's he's from England
than he is but he so anybody I was going
to say he's I hold him responsible for
these
excessive letters in in the address in
the URL I mean he's made us all say www
for a year or find some other way to say
it but it's not easy to say I think okay
whatever this is the operate the o.r
Center at MIT and then it's academics or
something and then it's something like
course offerings that's approximately
right and since they do apply to
optimization that's you know there's a
heading of ant data analytics or
statistics there's optimization there's
o-o-or operations research other lists
but a good list of courses from many
departments as president
especially so especially course sakes
of course 15 which is where the
operations Research Center are is course
18 and there are others in course too
and elsewhere yeah well would somebody
like to say what course you have in mind
to take next after this one if you
looked at the looked ahead to next year
any many suggestions of what looks like
a good course I I you know I only know I
sat in once on 6.03 six the really basic
course and you you would want to go
higher okay I I won't any maybe this is
just to say I'd be interested to know
what you do next what your experience is
or I'd be happy to give advice but maybe
my general advice is that that's a
useful list of
of courses okay back to distance
matrices okay so here's the problem
yep okay I'll probably have to raise
that but I'll leave it for a minute okay
so we know these distances and we want
to find the exit
so let's call this D IJ maybe so we have
a D matrix and we want to find the
position matrix let me just see what
notation so this is section 3.9 no 4.9
previously 3.9 but chapters three and
four got switched so and maybe maybe
actually yeah I think it's it's eight or
nine or ten it's other topics are trying
to find their way and okay so that's the
that's the reference on the lot on the
web and I'll get these sections onto
stellar okay so the question is can we
recover the positions from the distances
in fact there's also a question are
there always positions from the given
distances so let me and and I mentioned
several applications I've already spoken
about wireless sensor networks where you
you can measure travel times between
them between the sensors and then you
that gives you the distances and then
you use this neat little bit of math to
find the positions well of course you
can't find the positions uniquely
clearly you could any rigid motion of
all the positions if I have a set of
positions what am I going to call that X
so so right here and then
so I'm given the D matrix that's
distances and the job is to find the X
matrix which gives the positions and
what I'm just going to say and you
already saw that saw it in your mind
that if I have a set of positions I
could do a translation the distances
wouldn't change or I could do a rigid
motion other rigid rotation so positions
are not unique but I can make I can come
closer by saying put the center of
centroid at the origin or something like
that that will take out the translations
at least okay so find the X matrix
that's the job okay and I was going to
before I start on that the shapes of
molecules is another application nuclear
magnetic resonance gives distances gives
D and then we find the positions M X and
of course there's a noise in there and
sometimes missing entries and machine
learning could be just described also as
a you've given a whole lot of points in
space feature vectors in a high
dimensional space actually this is a big
deal you're given a whole lot of points
with where the in high dimensional space
and those are related there they're
there they sort of come together
naturally so they tend to fit on a
surface in high dimensional space a low
dimensional surface in high dimensional
space and really a lot of mathematics is
devoted to finding that low dimensional
that sub space but it could be curved so
sub space is not the correct word really
manifold is curved manifold this
a meth geometers would say that is close
to all the planets smooth and close to
all the points and you can linearize it
you could flatten it out and then you
have a much reduced problem the
dimension is reduced from the original
dimension of the of the where the points
lie with a lot of data to the true
dimension of the problem which of course
if the points were all on a straight
line the true dimension of the problem
would be one
well we so we have to discover this that
we also have to find that dimension D ok
ok so how do we do it so it's a
classical problem it just has a neat
answer ok okay so let's recognize the
connection between distances and
positions so D IJ is length of it's the
square distance between them so that is
X I X I minus X I XJ minus xj x i plus x
JX check ok is that right yes ok so
those are the DI J's in a matrix and
these are entries in the matrix D ok
well these entries
depend only on I they're the same for
every J so this is going to be this will
this this part will produce a rank one
matrix because things depend only on the
row but not on J their column number so
columns repeated yeah and this produces
a similarly something that depends only
on J only on the column number so the
rows are all the same so this is also a
rank one matrix with all repeated sent
all the same rows because if I change I
nothing changes in that inner product so
really these are the terms that produce
most of the matrix the significant part
of the matrix okay so what do we do with
those so what what
so let's see I've did I give a name for
the matrix that I'm looking for I think
in the notes I call it X so so I'm given
D given D find X and what I'll actually
find you can see it coming here is
actually find X transpose X because what
all I'm what I'm given is dot products
of X's so so I would like to find to
discover out of out of all this what X I
dotted with XJ is that'll be the correct
dot product let's call this matrix G for
the dot product matrix and then then
find X from G so this is a nice argument
so what this tells me is a bunch of some
information about dot products so this
is telling me something about the G
matrix the X transpose X matrix and then
once I know G then it's a separate step
to find X and of course that's this is
the point of which X is not unique if
there's if I put in a rotation into X
then that rotation Q will I'll see a Q
transpose Q and it'll disappear so the
so the I'm free to rotate the X's
because that doesn't change the dot
product but so it's G that I want to
know and this tells me something about G
and this tells me something about G and
so does that but that's what I have to
see so what is what do those tell me
let's see let me write down what I have
here so so the the the so let's say a
diagonal matrix with VII as the inner
product X I would X I that we that we're
getting partial information from here so
so is that okay I'm introducing that
notation because this is now going to
tell me that my D matrix is so what is
that so this is the diagonal matrix
maybe it's just a vector I should say
yeah yeah yep so can I write down the
equation that that that's that it's
fundamental here and then oh then we'll
figure out what it means so it's a
equation for G for the dot product
matrix okay let me make space for that
equation so here's the I believe that we
can get the dot product matrix which I'm
calling G as as according to this it's
minus 1/2 of the D matrix plus 1/2 of
the ones times the D the diagonal D and
it's plus 1/2 of the depth of the
the times and once these that's a matrix
with the same with constant rows that
matrix is that this here is this is
coming from there this is a matrix with
always the same columns so let me see no
I haven't got haven't got those right
yet I mean I want these to be rank one
matrices so I've it's this one that's
let me fix that one one one one times D
transpose so it's column times row and
this one is also column times row with
the D here okay now let me look at that
properly so every row in this guy is a
multiple of one one one one
so what does that telling me that all
columns are the same all columns are
this this part is is reflecting these
ones where the columns are repeated this
one is reflecting this where the rows
are repeated the D is just the set of D
numbers let's call that di and this is
DJ so all I'm and here's the D matrix
so part of the so so part of the D
matrix is is these is this pit and this
bit each giving a rank one now it's this
part that I have to understand
so let me while you're checking on that
let me okay yep let's just see where we
are if this is true if this is true I'm
given the D matrix and then these dot
products I can find so I can find these
so in other words this is the key
equation that tells me that's that's the
key equation and it's going to come just
from that simple identity just from
checking each term this term we
identified that last term we identified
it now this term is B well of course
it's D so I have two of those and I'm
going to take half of half of that to
get D I think yep yep and we'll we'll
look so so yeah
so I guess I'm not seeing right away why
this half is in here
but that's but I think I had it right
and there's there's a reason but you see
that this matrix this X transpose X
matrix is coming from these Rank 1
places and these pieces which are the
the cross-product oh oh I see I see what
really what that equation is really
saying is that the the D matrix is this
if I just read that along and translate
it and put it in matrix language is this
1 1 1 1 the 1 2 D for let's say
transpose is this Rank 1 matrix and the
other one is the DS times 1 1 which is
the transpose of that and then the other
one was a minus 2 of the cross product
matrices yep so when I write that
equation in matrix language I just get
that and now when I solve for x
oh it's 2 minus 2 X transpose X I just
yeah yep sorry
cross products the XS so I had one set
of cross products and then this is the
same as this so I have minus 2 of them
so now I'm just rewriting the that when
I rewrite that equation I have that do
you see that I put that on this side I
put D over here as a minus D I divide by
2 and then that's the formula so
ultimately this simple identity just
looked at because these pieces were so
simple just rank one pieces and this
these pieces were
actually what we want the X transpose X
pieces the G that equation told us the D
we know all this is known well so what's
really yeah what's known is D and this
and this so now we have the equation for
x transpose X is minus 1/2 of D minus
- these rank ones sorry to make it look
messy if I remember that Roger out T
talking about a last spring also the
algebra got flustered but so we get it
so we know X transpose X that matrix now
can you just can we just do four minutes
of linear algebra at the end today given
X transpose X find X this is n by n how
would you do that could you do it would
there be just one X know what so so any
if you had if you had one X multiply
that by a rotation by an orthogonal
matrix you'd have another one so so this
is you're finding X up to an orthogonal
transformation but how would you
actually do that well what do we know
about this matrix X transpose X
symmetric clearly and what we especially
know is that it's also positive or semi
definite so this is semi definite
so I'm given a semi definite matrix and
I want to find a square root you could
say that matrix is the X transpose X and
I want to find X I think there are two
leading candidates there are many
candidates because if you find one then
then any QX is okay yeah because if I
put a Q transpose Q in there it's the
identity okay so one way is to use eigen
values of x transpose x and the other
way would be to use elimination on X
transpose X so so for use so if I use
eigen values of X if I find the eigen
values of X transpose X then I'm writing
this as it's a symmetric
positive-definite writing it as Q lambda
Q transpose right that's the fundamental
most important theorem in the near
algebra you could say that a symmetric
positive semi definite matrix has
greater eigen values greater equal zero
and eigen vectors that are orthogonal so
now if I know that what's a good X then
take X to be what so I've got the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of X
transpose X and I'm looking for an X
that will work and one idea is just to
take the same eigen values eigen vectors
and take the square roots of the eigen
values because if I multiply if I track
that symmetric now this is equal to X
transpose
and if I so that was a that's a square
root symbol or a lambda to the one-half
I could I could say so when I multiply
that I'm just really X transpose X is
just x squared here when I square it the
Q transpose Q multiplies itself to give
the identity the square root of lambda x
times the square root of lambda is those
are diagonal matrices that give lambda
and I get the right answer so one way is
in a few words take the square roots of
the eigenvalues and keep the
eigenvectors so that's the eigenvalue
construction so that's producing an X
that is symmetric positive semi definite
that might be what you want it's a
little work because you're computing
eigenvalues and eigenvectors to do it
but that's one choice now I believe that
elimination would give us another choice
so elimination produces what
factorization of this this is still our
symmetric positive definite matrix if
you do elimination on that you you
usually expect L a lower triangular
times Z the the pivots times u the upper
triangular that's the usual result of of
elimination LD u I'm factoring out the
pivots so they're ones on the diagonals
of L and U but now if it's symmetric
matrix what's up we zip by elimination
regarding that as a 1806 trivial bit of
linear algebra but of course it's highly
important so what's the situation here
when the matrix is actually symmetric
the U so I want something to look
symmetric how do I make that look
symmetric the U gets replaced by L
transpose if I
if I if I'm working on a positive
definite say positive definite matrix
then I get positive pivots and L and
lower triangular and upper triangular or
transposes of each other so now what is
then
then what's the X it's just like that
I'll use L square root of D L transpose
is that right ooh wait a minute what's
up no that's not gonna work because I
don't have L transpose L where I had Q
transpose Q was good no sorry let's get
that totally erased the X part should
just be a square root of d L transpose
that's that's the X is now our
triangular matrix the square root of the
pivots and the L transpose part and now
when I do X transpose X then you you see
X transpose X coming correctly X
transpose will be L will be L transpose
transpose will give me the L square root
of D times square root of D will give
the D and then the L transpose is right
so this is called the do I try to write
it here this is my last word for today
the cholesky those are the this is the
cholesky factorization named after
french guy who a French soldier actually
so LD L transpose is cholesky and that's
that's easy to compute much faster to
compute than the eigen value of square
root but this square root is triangular
this square root is symmetric those are
the two sort of pieces of linear algebra
to find things to reduce things to
triangular form or to reduce them to
to connect them with symmetric matrices
okay thank you for attention today so
today we did the distance matrices and
this was the final step to get the X and
also getting the more most important was
to get the structure of a neural net
straight separating the V's the sample
vectors from the X's the weights okay so
Friday I've got one volunteer to talk
about a project and I'm desperately
looking for more please just send me an
email you're in your your it'll be
appreciated or I'll send you an email if
necessary okay thanks